luján un hombre que se ha convertido en
sinónimo de los inicios de la pandemia
de ccoo being 1911 millones de personas
las primeras del mundo en experimentar
la contención en 2020 durante más de dos
meses oficialmente aquí han muerto tres
mil 869 personas a causa de coronavirus
según algunas estimaciones podría ser
hasta tres veces más dos años después no
se ha registrado ningún caso positivo
durante meses para los mujeres es los
días oscuros de la enfermedad ya más
la vida es tranquila la epidemia no
vuelve a empezar aquí todo el mundo me
estaba evitando
seguimos teniendo cuidado pero ya no
tenemos miedo la ciudad es completamente
normal
luján es la ciudad más segura los genes
la ciudad de los héroes sus habitantes
son héroes valor solidaridad victoria
esto es lo que los habitantes quieren
recordar por encima de todo
temas que inspiran a los artistas y
ansían pinta escenas tradicionales para
gloria de los guyaneses
con este cuadro quiero mostrar la unidad
del pueblo durante la pandemia este
valor y espíritu de resistencia viene de
nuestros antepasados durante la crisis
fue una de las voluntarias repartiendo
medicamentos alimentos ayudando a los
pacientes a encontrar una cama el
recuerdo de la angustia en los
hospitales no la ha abandonado
durante la crisis ella hizo parte de los
voluntarios que entregaban comida
medicamentos y ayudaba a los pacientes a
encontrar una cama el recuerdo y la
angustia de esos días aún la acompañan
nadie hablaba cuando entré en el
hospital el único sonido que podía oír
era el de la gente esto siempre está
escena realmente me asusta
pero elegí quedarme
al 600
el trauma permanece pero el discurso
oficial insiste en la resiliencia eso
trata esta película el melodrama cuenta
la historia del encierro de un jan una
versión muy ficticia de los destinos de
los héroes ordinarios todos unidos en la
batalla contra el virus el escenario
gusta ha sido número uno en los cines
chinos desde su estreno el 7 de enero
sentí mucha fatiga cuando vi la película
los cuidadores de los hospitales y los
voluntarios fueron extraordinarios
me sentí exactamente igual que entonces
yo misma lo experimenté y no fue fácil
esos relatos estas historias de victoria
ocultan las zonas de sombra de kobe 19
en wuhan es la ciudad la cuna de la
pandemia no las autoridades chinas
sostienen que el virus provino del
extranjero en un hang sin embargo las
sospechas aún persisten sobre el mercado
un lugar donde se venden animales
salvajes atrincherados durante dos años
y en el laboratorio p4 donde se
estudiarán los coronavirus chinas se ha
negado a permitir que el estudio de la
oms en estas zonas continúe en el verano
de 2021 la opacidad de las autoridades
impide cualquier consenso científico y
cualquier cuestionamiento shanghai es
uno de los últimos en criticar
abiertamente al gobierno su padre murió
de covite hace dos años se infectó en un
hospital de busán shanghai lo había
llevado allí para una operación de
rutina sin saber del virus en ese
momento
tras la muerte de mi padre pregunté por
ahí y me enteré de que el virus había
aparecido en wuhan
mucho antes de que yo fuera allí el
gobierno local de buján lo había
ocultado si hubiera sabido que el
coronavirus existía en wuhan seguramente
no habría vuelto a la ciudad
shanghai presentó una queja contra las
instituciones por no haber advertido a
la población a tiempo solicitudes
rechazadas a pesar de los riesgos sigue
denunciando el silencio de las
autoridades
incluso dos años después estoy furioso
las autoridades mintieron diciendo que
la enfermedad era controlable y que no
había transmisión de persona a persona
inmediatamente reprimieron a personas
como él y william que se atrevieron a
presentarse para advertir a la gente
al igual yang médico denunciante ahora
único no fue uno de los primeros en
denunciar una misteriosa neumonía en
luján antes de morir a causa de ella
después de provocar la ira de los
internautas al acusarlo inicialmente de
difundir falsos rumores las autoridades
se vieron obligadas a limpiar su nombre
incluso hoy sus redes sociales están
inundadas de homenajes no te hemos
olvidado
gracias por tu valor
usted es mi héroe
pero la mayoría de los denunciantes de
wuhan no han sido rehabilitados en estos
vídeos el periodista ciudadano yangjiang
mostraba a los hospitales superpoblados
y la vida confinada hola hoy es el 13 de
mayo de 2020 mi nombre es yang yang este
es su último vídeo fue detenida poco
después y condenada a cuatro años de
prisión por causar disturbios ahora está
en huelga de hambre sus familiares temen
por su vida
otros denunciantes también han sido
detenidos durante meses uno de ellos
bank being no ha sido visto desde hace
casi dos años
testimonios como borrados de la memoria
oficial de la pandemia en un hand